our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
really far greater than what divides us
this morning we're introducing you to
two co-workers with a very special bond
nurse Velma Wong and medical resident
Brandon cementery work in the neonatal
intensive care unit at Lucile Packard
Children's Hospital in Stanford but they
first met there years ago under very
different circumstances
Matea via Adele has her story it's my
parents would always tell me about how
little I was and how scared they were
for me born about three months premature
Brandon Semin Ettore weighed less than
two and a half pounds when he was moved
to the neonatal intensive care unit or
NICU back in 1990 now nearly three
decades later he's treating patients at
the same hospital where he spent the
first days of his life coming here for
residency is just like the cherry on top
honestly to be able to be a doctor in
the hospital I was born in he was doing
his rounds last month when he ran into a
nurse who told him his name sounded
familiar and then I say was your father
a police officer and then I was big
ciders and that's when he said to me I
hear Velma for years Seminole Tory's
parents had told him about nurse Velma
Velma Wong had cared for him when he was
a newborn I actually had to text my
parents I had to be like so I think I
met this person who is the person you
keep telling me about and then they sent
the picture you see the picture what was
your reaction I was in shock
where he's just like smiling and we
could look at you ain't going keep him
be that it just didn't seem real rank
how how could this be the nurse that was
helping take care of me what was it that
surprised you most about that picture oh
it's just the hair and big glasses and
you're looking back saying oh my god we
all have big hair
on Sunday seminar Tori's parents had
their chance to reconnect it happened at
an event the hospital holds every year
designed to bring together NICU
patient's with their doctors and nurses
seminar Tori's parents now hope their
son can have the same connection with
the families
he helps it's amazing that he did come
from full circle but I'm hoping that he
will make an impact on future families
the way that Vilma has made an impact on
our family here and mom talk about you
now I mean it's got to feel like you
truly made an impact amazing you know
it's like I can't describe it it's just
this deep joy and happiness some 30
years later Wong has no plans to retire
in fact both she and Seminar Tory hope
their fateful meeting will inspire other
NICU families to see that the most
fulfilled lives can come from the most
humble beginnings I think he's a role
model for a patient and sometime is good
to say you know I took care of Brandon
he said doctor it's just to give me a
little real hope you know you know
that's very important
for CBS this morning media vol Palo Alto
California it really is a full-circle
moment for both sides I marvel that she
could remember his name and that he
could say I always heard about nurse
Vilma is it you what a blessing to be
able to actually meet your guardian
angel person it yeah it's really
responsible that you're still here
bonded for life I say monitor life